[Música]
boa tarde
é bom hoje o fabril 6 é sobre a
diversidade humana às empresas
bom eu escolhi esse tema porque eu acho
muito injusto que uma pessoa não tenha
as mesmas oportunidades que outros
dentro de uma empresa simplesmente pelo
fato de já ser considerada diferente na
nossa sociedade
um exemplo disso é que no brasil os
negros recebem em média 1.200 reais a
menos que os brancos o que é um absurdo
você parar para pensar que o salário
mínimo atual aqui no brasil é de em
média mil reais com esses gráficos podem
mostrar os brancos muitas vezes são
contratados para trabalhos mais
valorizados como por exemplo o
comissário de vôo e os negros são
completados na maioria das vezes para os
trabalhos menos valorizados como
operador de telemarketing ou criador de
camarões mas os negros não são os únicos
injustiçados pois pesquisa de 2017
apontam que apenas 1% dos deficientes
estavam no mercado de trabalho
outro absurdo ocorre com as mulheres que
muitas vezes deixam de ser contratadas
por o fato de terem filhos menores de
seis anos ou simplesmente por poderem
acaba engravidando
além de quando serem contratadas muitas
vezes recebendo é o salário 20% menor do
que o dos homens
isso é muito ruim tanto para empresa
tanto para a pessoa que está deixando de
ser contratada pois empresas que
investem na diversidade possuem equipes
talentosas inovadoras china maior
eficiência e produtividade e assim
valorizando as ações dessa empresa e bom
você que está aqui me assistindo agora
olhe ao seu redor e perceba a diferença
entre todas as pessoas que estão nesse
auditório
reparem que tem pessoas com óculos mais
baixos mais altas com cores diferentes
na pele no cabelo nos olhos
agora pense que todas as pessoas devem
ter as mesmas oportunidades dentro de
uma empresa
e se você conhece algum empresário
conversa com ele e falha da importância
da contratação de pessoas diversas na
sua empresa
obrigado pela atenção
[Aplausos]
[Música]